good morning Millennials food morning
meal any a happy pi day three should
read it out three fourteen I thought you
said three four two I was like oh no
it's a really one one four one five nine
six really
let's read it out you know Dana knows
all the numbers of Pi by heart that's
just one for claims to fame if I
realized it was pi day maybe we could
have gotten her on the show I think it's
okay trust me wait hold on hold on
I didn't realize you knew that it was pi
day as well cuz they told me was bad day
oh really I saw her answer I'm like not
two seconds ago oh okay go 3.14159 six
nine two six [ __ ] that's pretty good
that's more than I know yeah should I
read them all for their what the [ __ ] is
pi like it's so loser e it yeah like the
circumference of a circle sure the
number is a mathematical constant
originally defined as the ratio of a
circles circumference is that what I
said dereference hey hey this old thing
but doesn't it just depend on the size
of the circle but it's like circles no
matter if big or small circle like a
circle has that property about it that
makes it a circle that I believe is PI
whatever it just seems like the nerdiest
thing like prime right and it has like
its own sign you know
no it's for nerds but it's cute and it's
like nerds get excited about it and like
Dana gets excited about it
it's really [ __ ] she's queen of the
Nerds and I'm you know what it's such
like a wholesome whole thing true yes
that's true whole sums and it's like
it's something exciting and it's like
exciting that three points March 14th is
Pi Day March 15th is the Ides of March
when Caesar was killed
she's totally stab Caesar a tu brute a
so tomorrow I'll be stabbing Claudia
okay and I will up down you're doing
right honestly being dead sound slit and
then you can say it to Jackie hey
everything this a to Jack hey well
welcome back to the morning shows it
hasn't been Jackie and I for awhile
let's just quickly recap the madness
that was yesterday because we were in
the presence of an icon we really were
and you know we were like no like when
she got here she like wanted to powder
her nose and stuff and she like wanted a
copy and we were like [ __ ] it's 10:35
but like I don't tell the countess what
to do you know maybe probably at 10:29
and she's in no rush and she was like I
will take a coffee and where's the
bathroom so we got her coffee and showed
her to powder her nose checked her
statement necklace she just was like
running like super slow but like I
didn't care she was in no rush and you
know I want to run on countess time you
know drinking tea I have a general lung
we were like oh the toasters will
understand when we get an opportunity to
tell them which we would have told you
on Instagram yesterday I was down how
was your day its way since I didn't see
you because you weren't on Instagram
well we were together yeah we were
together recording premium content we
recorded Claudia's home tour finally
it's literally 30 minutes of premium
content I felt very vulnerable I don't I
don't like having my home out there no
it's very personal yeah and like there
was like a million things I had to do
before the tour like shove all the
laundry in the corner you know right
nobody puts laundry in a corner which
you did and feel was on his best
behavior he woke up his room he was like
really shook when we came home we're
like feel we're doing the home tour and
he was like oh my god I gotta clean my
room but we helped him he's so cute he
sleeps with a bottle of tequila fun fact
about him just like his mother
like mother like son and you guys should
check it out he tried combo it's out
there and I'm just I'm feeling very
nervous about it I don't know people are
so judgmental when it comes to like home
decor and I can't tell like if I did a
spectacular job decorating my apartment
or like I live in a sewer I can't decide
well I can tell you that there's
absolutely nothing controversial about
the way you've decorated your apartment
I know that there's anything that people
could say I mean obviously there's
always [ __ ] who will find something
nasty to Ted to say but like further
they're not picture we're well-meaning
people I don't think that there's
anything that they could say even if
it's not for them there's nothing like
crazy about it you know it's just like
in my last apartment I felt very sure of
my decors style because I was very into
just like because you're near one room
to decorate mirror Mara Mara Mara mirror
on the wall who thought east of them all
me but in this department I went for a
slightly more modern more mature
contemporary style and I'm just I like
it I just don't know you know it's just
different I'm not feeling as sure of
myself and there weren't that many
comments on the picture I'm post too
like
I was looking for some validation there
and I didn't find it right speaking of
validation then we also did an episode
that's coming up tomorrow where I took
the anagram test which I have taken I'm
a tape of three I don't want to talk
about it
Jackie took it stay tuned to see what
number she is but I want you guys to
guess what you think I am that's a good
idea um if you are familiar with this
cuz I didn't and then I was explaining
it to Zach when I got home and I was
reading all the personality types and of
course when I told him what I am he's
like you're not that because he thinks
he's more that than I am
oh no he is AG you on Iraq but then I
was reading all the different
personality types and I I think I know
which one he is you know I'm gonna do it
with him if the toasters were to read
the personality types they'd be like
totally now I'm a type 3 and also when
he invented it together on another
patron episode so if you sounded for
patreon now you can get that episode -
it was really funny Ben was like not
understanding the test whatsoever but
then he obviously got the most like
flattering personality types - Kevin
so that's it and I'm gonna member and 7
7 7 and it really like hit the nail on
the head when describing bad mine did
too but like in a much less flattering
way like basically I'm aggressive and
all I care is for people to like me and
think I'm cool it's true I hope you guys
think she's cool yeah all that matters
because like apparently I'm kept up at
night crippling with fear that people
don't like me or think that I'm
successful so please tell her to please
thumbs up on this video subscribe to our
YouTube channel follow me on Instagram
follow me on Instagram pop up with no
job on Instagram who's back on his
[ __ ] posting premium content he took
a break and he needed to and honestly
like so did we he was just like relaxing
he gained some wings which wasn't really
feeling himself but he's back and he's
looking better than ever yeah feeling
good too
yes he's extra staticky he's excited for
spring so he can lose his winter static
so I'm thinking about getting a second
hole a parsing hole so and then this
idea only comes about because Alison Lou
who is jewelry designer who parsed
Jackie's ears live live on the morning
breath I would turn engagement party
last night and then they said I bring
another piercing party today and I think
I'm gonna get a second hole I know it's
like not crazy at all like most my
friends have like three or four but like
I don't know I'm just like a
conservative gal yeah but I think I'm
gonna do it I think it's cool I think
you shouldn't I think like if you get
your ear parsed there you've got like a
discount I mean it's really why I'm
doing it all right but also her earrings
are so cute cuz they sell them like
individually because they're made for
like [ __ ] parsing parties so like you
can
I think you should get like a flame well
I everyone was wearing their Allison
Lulu sites to the engagement party
Lester like everyone in the crowd was
right I had a bra from was there she had
really cute like a mini army green ones
that's hilarious and then also I was
looking around the room and I'm like
damn that girl looks a lot like Jennifer
Lawrence then someone goes to me
did you see Jennifer Lawrence and I'm
like I did it was actually her how did
she look literally stunning like pure
perfection honestly I was like trying
not to be a freak so I got close once
and then I like let her lippert like
she's now just like roses she just
looked so cool is she happy to be there
yeah she was having a great time and she
was just like enjoying all the different
facets of the party like the bar the
food the couch the dance floor you know
yeah Wow I really enjoyed it
very cool so yeah I'm thinking I got a
second well I'll go live on Instagram
and you'll have to hold it for me cuz
I'm gonna be freaking out okay I'm down
to go cuz I could I could check out some
jewelry now that I'm like a jewelry
wearing should I get a button pierced
yes right above my Fupa that'll be a
nice thing to maybe distract from my
hanging Fupa you know what I wouldn't be
surprised if Alison Lowe has like a no
belly button policy for their party part
it's too classy for that I don't think
she makes the belly button ring should I
get a nose ring no no there's only so
many rings you can get I know but like a
tongue that's cool yeah and that's a
look now when I do my comedy and I'm
like you're not hardcore unless you live
hardcore that's so true those are such
important words to live by just like
Tyler Perry oh my god we have started my
real house in New York I actually
watched it this morning because last
night I had the engagement party oh my
god also last night I was asked a couple
weeks ago to attend this event and it
was for my high school the parents
council and you know I thought it was
prestigious that they asked me to like
emcee the auction to raise money for the
school Larry and you know I was honored
and I was really not looking forward to
it because it's like an awkward thing
you know but I did it and I went last
night before the engagement party and I
just have to say like the parents
council like did not care about me at
all like I tried to calm the room down
nobody even turned around like people
have their backs towards me they were
still at the bar like I was literally
talking to just Ben and Caroline the
male cow on the Bell who was Jackie
Snider
Jackie's friend from high school and she
was obviously on the parents council
she's like the coolest mom out there she
was like in the front row like
videotaping me it was
and then I'm yeah she is so cute I felt
like very disrespected by the parents
council whatever you did what you had to
do and you know what now I'm sure that
also was a bad night for you to go
because I'm sure the whole parents
council was talking about the scandal
being down the cheating scandal oh yeah
you think a hundred percent that's like
a thing parents are like loving now I
guess right I think like all the much
has happened is that once over yeah
we're going to talk about it even though
it's guys do not like our take out no
it's getting a lot worse it's getting
worse I've been really I don't know I
guess cuz I'm no longer wedding planning
I'm like home a little bit more I have
daily pop on in the background maybe
I'll even do some news except they don't
give hot take sunny news they just give
you the news they don't give you
personality or opinions
oh no news is horrible right but like
sometimes I just like to know what other
shows are talking about or have we
missed a major storm right I watched the
real yesterday only because Steel
stepped on the clicker and accidentally
put it on he loves the real but I love I
and I don't know her name but I saw her
on Worst Cooks in America a celebrity
edition it's hurting Lori the girl from
the view from the real I'm sure can real
I [ __ ] love her CEO she knows people
who is just funny in her body like the
way that she talks is funny okay
tomorrow Mary
Loni love Loni love oh she's hilarious
and she was just on Real Housewives of
Atlanta I was watching an old episode
like she's so funny but that other woman
we go back to the janitor named Jenny
yes I'm making up names yes her name is
Jenny May she did stuff a little too
seriously she was on the red carpet for
whatever so I was watching and there
were a lot of technical difficulties and
it fell on her no well I love Tia
tomorrow Mary I forget what your planner
I love Loni love I love Adrienne Bailon
the girl Jenny like just takes herself a
little too seriously but I guess she
keeps the show but it always has to but
I just think it's a great show and they
have like a bad time sign and they look
at enough like like they're honestly
just as important as the view I want to
say they just talk about things that we
care about more if a few it's the view
but they don't really talk about
hard-hitting stuff which I love and they
all really offer a diverse opinion on
everything so I joined they do get like
some some good some respect and I was a
guest on there like I had no idea who he
was no I think I think they do well for
themselves and at least like they have
it do you need to make a lot of money
I'm sure they have like a
decent contract channels on I think Theo
pest press three okay like what Siri
hold on now I can't open another oh I
think it's Fox yeah I mean that's legit
I mean I take it you know right might
not like what's the thing they say about
beggars they can't be choosers that's
the real channel I feel like it's just
kind of show that's on a different
channel for everyone it's on kpl our TV
excuse me
um I think it's on Fox yeah I think so
too maybe press five I don't know he
what he's always you know he knows
always you know um introducing me to new
content yeah I don't know by the way TV
stations and this whole network
education I don't understand if they're
that reason I don't think we can ever be
on TV
Jackie and I were gonna meeting and they
were like trying to explain like how
date time works like if you get a pilot
and they're like in the broadcasting and
like each region has their own likes
tribute er and I was like I just want to
be on Bravo like how do we do that I
think with those kinds of channels it's
a lot easier than like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10
yes for sure but it's still so confusing
because listen to this I'm just I just
googled the real channel kpl our TV
virtual channel 11 is a CW affiliate a
television station licensed to st. Louis
Missouri the station is owned by Tribune
Broadcasting subsidiary of the Tribune
Media Company as a part of a duopoly
with Fox affiliate KTVI why the [ __ ]
does that mean and that's just and
that's the summer blurb ya know it's
that they love that word affiliate the
toast is well I guess we're YouTube's
affiliates you know where YouTube and
podcast podcast affiliate as well as
Spotify I Heart Radio public radio edit
a stitcher anywhere podcast can be
listened to
that's a thing well we're a multimedia
platform yes I just love multimedia it
might take a lot of the art in your
apartment yes my a lot of the art in my
apartment is very militant medium we
went into a very in-depth art discussion
on my youtube home tour channel whatever
it's called
hey Chad knock on Sasha morning toast
you'll patreon affiliate thank you you
know this stress so I was going through
my closet I don't know why I feel like
spring is sprung me I've decided I'm
stopping to wear jackets right and now
that I'm moving you know I'm gonna have
to clean out my closet so I was going
through my actual clothes like that you
know you have a chunk of your whole
closet that you actually never actually
called the things that you wear on the
top of your bureau so it was like you
know what let me see do I have anything
that I would wear and I got this dress
two years ago in Israel I think was like
two years ago today because I might
I'm hot we were in Israel two years ago
and I wore it once on the breath and it
looked horrible because our desks were
up here and I was wearing like a awful
colored shirt what though kind of washes
out the color isn't great but like the
vibe is cute and honestly it'll be
better on the show than it does in real
life right now which never happens I was
gonna throw it out or give it away after
I wore it today but maybe I'll keep it I
saw myself on the toast yesterday and I
vowed to make a more conscious effort to
give the people something nice because I
just was looking at myself and that
necklace I was wearing just like Janaka
with my sweater and that sweater that I
wear didn't operate the countess but
this sweater has been burnt alive my
hair was like wrinkly as [ __ ] like I was
just looking like actually like someone
who doesn't deserve to be on this
prestigious platform so now today I feel
as if I'm dressed a little bit more I
just hate wearing all black but every
time I don't I immediately regret it
right and that shirt is like really kind
of like jazzy for 10:38 no it's from sex
fit Avenue I only shop at Saks Fifth
Avenue in the sale department and this
shirt was like four-inch dollars that I
got for 121 dollars very cool
I was I was surfing the internet last
night looking like shopping looking for
some sales he ever text you during the
toast and it's like I'm busy then just
text me this better be life or death for
messages ooh what could it be it's the
oh okay he's making plans for a wedding
like I can't I can't they don't you know
I can't that really would matter mate
should we finish we should FaceTime him
call him out no because like he won't
even answer yeah and he'll just be like
you do season what were we saying
oh I was shopping last night because I'm
like remember what back-to-school
shopping used to get like fall clothes
and spring closing you step clothes and
now like you never do that anymore and
then in the middle of the season I
realized I need it what I'm like the
seasons about to change and now so I'm
really trying to get ahead of it we
didn't like get close because we have to
look nice every day and I it's hard I'm
like last spring I look like a train
wreck on the show and you know maybe was
a difficult time for us and I was
stressed out a lot going on I was
planning wedding I was moving but this
year I don't have that excuse and I want
to serve you guys like a good spring
look like looks every day are you
interesting to look at that's it's such
a hard thing to do yeah but it's so
important in this industry that we work
in yeah we don't even like work in a
real industry but I get it we made up
our own industry but I always am like
for the industry we're in
and if you want to be whether I'm always
comparing myself to like industries that
like I want to be and like when I'm
talking to someone who's like obviously
really successful my Camino in our
industry they're right even though it's
like you're in the media industry or and
the TV industry you're in the comedy
industry influence our industry digital
industry I'm in whatever industry I feel
like in the technology industry I'll be
in the coal mining industry I'll be like
my back hurts I'm in whatever industry
the money is that right we're just
industrious ok I think I'm ready I'm so
I've been so hungry like when I'm been
waking up I need to like figure it out
yeah it's hell breakfast no but yeah I
would say I don't ever I never had time
for breakfast but you had time to watch
or how many this morning so you have
time yeah because I knew we needed to
talk about it and I didn't get a chance
to watch the last night's show without
further ado it is I believe let me check
my watch yes it's time to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
okay first story shook the world to the
core except no one could talk about it
because Facebook struggled to deal with
an epic outage yesterday a partial
Facebook outage affecting users around
the world has stretched beyond 14 hours
but showing some signs of ending early
Thursday it's believed to be the biggest
interruption ever suffered by the social
network Facebook the world's largest
social network had turned had to turn to
its rival Twitter to explain that its
group of hugely popular apps were having
difficulties some users of Facebook and
other platforms owned by the tech giant
including Instagram messenger in
whatsapp reported intermittent problems
accessing the services and posting
content the outage appeared to be
abating early Thursday at 12:41 a.m.
Eastern Time Instagram posted a tweet
that said and we're back with a gif of
Oprah Winfrey Winfrey they were annoying
the [ __ ] out of me because I just want
to say we did the toast yesterday Beth
when I was on my phone a little bit
afterwards and then from like noon on
there was no Instagram so then in
Instagram didn't actually even
acknowledge it or tweet till like 7:00
p.m. I was without Instagram I was so
[ __ ] bored like it's it's my whole
life not only like for enjoyment but
also for works like it felt like we
didn't even do the toast yesterday
because I didn't even get to like
promote it on Instagram and [ __ ] and I
was so bored I was literally refreshing
Twitter there was like nothing going on
I I just I don't even know what I did
yesterday yeah I kind of enjoyed it
except from a work perspective um
we didn't get to promote the episode
sorry I use in my mouth we went and did
it get to promote the episode we had the
home tour yeah it was just like a post
about it on Facebook
I didn't realize Facebook was down for
like six hours later when I went to post
something and I couldn't post but I was
able to like scroll you yet Facebook
wasn't it wasn't gonna in tablet but
what's up was down to him like the
International folk were freaking out Wow
I was like Facebook's whole stable of
apps and now I'm wondering what happened
it wasn't an attack was it the Russian
he said it wasn't a DDoS attack but like
I understand you know things go down but
for all of Facebook like Facebook's
whole system to be down and they
couldn't get it back up like I can't
even imagine what it was like at
Facebook yesterday like everyone was
pretty girl just like went home I would
cuz it's like if I'm working on
Instagram and say I'm just like you know
a social media coordinator like there's
nothing I can do to help the outage so
I'm taking a day off well speaking of
social media coordinators the person who
was running the Twitter at E was like
really trying so hard to be funny like
I'm a social media editor and I'm dying
like it was literally the least funny
like few tweets actually find them oh
yeah it was just like really they try so
hard and very few times does it actually
like pay off for them but it does you
know they have their moments
hold on now I got to scroll down cuz
instrum since Facebook and Instagram are
still down what books have you been
reading lately teching taking steps
towards becoming less phone addicted
please help they did a summoning circle
I don't think like a blogger yeah no it
was really not funny like black mayor
episode idea Facebook and Instagram are
down social media editor tries to figure
out life's purpose without them I'm dark
question mark I don't think I would I'll
catch that one yeah no it was just like
really not funny and they were trying
super hardened I guess like they didn't
get that that's what happens when like
they don't give you the day off
when your job is right literally it
doesn't exist yeah and then you have to
make [ __ ] up yeah you know I was
literally just like yesterday should
have been productive for me like I
should have just like you know been
doing grocery shopping like but I just
like sat refreshing even though it
wasn't working do you don't II mean yeah
it's what the definition of and Saturday
is doing the same thing over and
expecting different results
I went to Instagram probably every three
or four minutes just refreshed yeah I
kept thinking like right by now I would
like every guy what do you think by now
it's it's back up yeah and it wasn't it
was just it's really crazy to think
about like what happened that they
couldn't fix and it affected my business
I had to do I was starting a partnership
with a brand yesterday and I had to
postpone it me too till today premium
content calculated a one o'clock for me
which I'm actually excited for this
partnership it's in the evening for me
because I feel like it's very apropos to
just like our lifestyle no totally so
exciting so very same anyway also I had
one more thing to say about Facebook and
Instagram you know it was actually I had
this conversation with Ben last night I
feel like maybe like a year or two ago
if Instagram had went down me and Ben
were like what if it never comes back
like Instagram hadn't come back ever
a year ago I probably would have needed
to pick my life up and like get a real
job yeah because my whole life is
incumbent upon wasn't coming upon money
I was making via instant right after the
mental breakdown that you have right but
then I was like okay let's say Instagram
never comes back I feel like I'd be okay
you would be okay like they were on
another platform would pop off and I
feel like the toasters would follow us
they're like I just don't feel anymore
like so reliant on this app that like if
it were to die one day like vine was
gone in the day and when the day before
that it was the biggest app out there so
if that happened to Instagram like I
feel pretty strong but like I would
survive and that felt really good
no I was seeing on the same thing like
hey Instagram never comes back like what
does that mean for the toast I was like
actually the truth doesn't do anything
like Instagram reliant obviously of the
Facebook groups but you know we will
figure it out generate just Instagram
like I know Facebook at the same company
but like Facebook's I'm going on but
like nothing is forever yet and so like
I mean you could say the same thing okay
so we would go to youtube and do the
show but like you know you as something
can happen to you too but it's like you
do your tour that is so offline right I
just think I think we'd be okay and that
feels really really good you can build a
website I don't know if a lot of
influencers could say that you know no I
agree and I had the same thought and I
was like hey a counsel yeah that's me I
buy back for this I guess you just have
to promote you chorus somewhere else
like the morning toast if you're like us
and just our running rampant with UTIs
no I'm kidding but I live in constant
fear that I'm gonna get UTIs and that's
like the worst part UTI it's like
waiting waiting for a UTI is like
waiting for rain in this drought a la
Hilary Duff
no but they UTI is just always waiting
around the corner no no it's literally
like it's Justin Bieber as interim
stories waiting for Haley Baldwin to
come around the corner
everybody accidentally scared us
neighbor did you see that now oh my god
it was so funny um and I feel like the
worst part about UTIs is like just
waiting for it to come like you can feel
it's coming and there's nothing you can
do about it until now because you'll
Cora is a powder that you mix into your
water it tastes like pink lemonade and
it helps prevent UTIs which is like it's
the only thing out there right now that
actually helps prevent UTIs before they
come so you can ease your vagina but
also your state of mind
so you core was developed using the best
research available in collaboration with
the team of physicians you Korra's
unique formula targets bacteria and
enables you to safely flush bacteria out
of your urinary tract stopping UTIs
before they even start can you Cora and
say goodbye to UTIs right now you core
is offering 30% off when you Tex toast
two four eight four eight four eight but
hurry it's a limited time offer just
text toast to 48 48 48 to get 30% off
your first order of you Cora that's to8
st 2 for 8 for 8 for 8 worth it worth it
ok are you ready for the next story that
is maybe just like feminist icons
without you Cora like I think so sorry
UT I think I dress like a packet of you
Cora today well thank you they have very
nice branding yet with our UTI awareness
yeah I feel like a couple years ago
became trendy to like be open about your
period which like I'll never do but now
I'm just getting there with UTIs yeah
like there was like articles like this
photographer photographed women on their
periods in underwear without tampons
isn't it inspiring I'm like no that's
disgusting
yeah I'm sorry like I'm all for
embracing womanhood but like oh yeah
that's what it was yeah and it's like
this woman's a hero for not wearing a
tampon and walking about with her blood
stains it's like no I'm sorry I don't I
don't agree I don't agree either also
that was the same time I was like this
woman took a selfie every day for a year
and this is what she found it's like we
all do that that was when BuzzFeed was
like at its most out of control yeah now
they've like had to layoff a few people
so there aren't as many articles of
people being out of control remember
that 22 things you secretly do as a
woman and I was like getting ready to be
like oh I'm embarrassed like I do
actually do that no it was the craziest
thing it's like feel your pubes through
your underwear I like the feeling it's
like hold on remember that
I have to find it open or that article
now that's like where it's a meme where
it's like this person went to journalism
school for this and it's like 22
celebrities who look nothing alike right
22 things like Ogura and Channing Tatum
hold on oh went to journalism school for
that you rise that's why College is
really important okay drive your way
into 44 things sorry 44 secret gross
things that all girls do but don't talk
about okay I'll be wearing the bra for
at least a week yeah that's why you
started it you really this is me you can
read them it just gets worse and crazier
really enjoying digging out ingrown
hairs okay they're on to something
they're having whole sessions with the
tweezers when you get every single one
no whole sessions what do you I don't
know okay oh this is what I meant
twiddling your pubes in a totally non
sexy way now I don't do that actually
owning a pair of scissors that you
exclusively use to trim your pubes whose
ribs refuse get a razor badge or a wax
but also being telling you literally
said that verbatim on the last time a
year a year two years ago Wow
removing all your pubes and regretting
it instantly because you look like an
oversized baby you just called me fact
secretly thinking this is a good look
still wearing old knickers and creating
a little pube ponytail through the whole
that was that was where they lost me
number 23 still wearing old nikka's and
creating a little pube ponytail through
the hole no I don't relate to that on
any level oh they have a little sketch
of it oh my god we literally had this
exact conversation including to have a
little sketch of it and then I'm pretty
sure me realized was BuzzFeed UK I mean
just chalked it up to that they do some
weird [ __ ] in the UK they do some weird
[ __ ] in the UK let you put it there
sister how they get their period yes yes
yes the UTI activists that we are okay
next story serious bits Joe Giudice
released from prison into IC e custody
as possible deportation looms Joe
Giudice was Rhys released from federal
prison but he isn't totally a free man
Teresa Giudice has been was released
from Allenwood low Federal Correctional
Institute
in Pennsylvania on Thursday morning but
remains in federal custody with the US
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
I see page six confirmed mr. Giudice is
currently an icy custody at the pending
immigration proceedings Joe is awaiting
a ruling about his ongoing deportation
case which could result in the former
Real Housewives of New Jersey start
moving back to his native Italy Judy Joe
whose real name is Giuseppe Giudice be
deported Terenas said she and her
daughter's wouldn't go with him quote I
hope that's not a decision I have to
make she said at the Reunion when asked
if she'd followed her husband but like
to pick up my children and just move to
another country I don't know that would
be good for my children so I mean no I
probably wouldn't well then I also read
if the appeal doesn't go through and he
does end up having to be deported he
will not be able to go home or whatever
like he literally goes from jail to
Italy yeah and that's happening today
which is crazy like it's up today time's
up
so they're deciding on the appeal today
yeah well I I don't even know like I
mean I know they appealed it but I don't
know if that did anything right I don't
know what they actually have to decide
today I think that I thought that the
decision had been made
we never got news from when it was
appealed to now that things might even
possibly change like I think this is
very much a sure thing like I mean it's
so sad it reminds me of this latest
season of orange is the new black where
this girl's getting out and she's like
so cute with her boyfriend and they're
like getting ready to have a baby
and he's like waiting for her at the
jail like doors and they take her out
the back and put her on a bus back to
Mexico because she was not a US citizen
and it's like so sad her boyfriend's
waiting for them and then the season
ends Wow I know very very similar that
that is uh so at this point I think I
would actually be more surprised if he's
able to stay here then I would be if I'm
expecting him to go back to Italy
meemers already said right it doesn't
seem and it doesn't seem like the judge
I don't know if it's been the same judge
throughout their whole case but they
have they're not you know they're not
making any allowances for the Giudices
they're not cutting any corners yeah
they're not sympathetic at all no it
seems like whatever Judges's like has a
hard-on for Bravo it seems like whatever
judge just says is Team Caroline Manzo
totally maybe Dina Manzo is like in his
ear no Jenna and Teresa but it's like
Albie don't be gal totally friends in
high places
speaking of I want to jump to the next
story because it's sort of related it's
having friends in high places and just
like you know abusing your privilege no
it's actually like more related than
that did you hear the story this morning
the Gambino crime family boss Frank Ali
was shot dead outside his Staten Island
home okay it's a big story I saw it and
at first I was like that's not toast
material but it's actually really big
news Gambino crime Ross Francesco
Frankie boy Khali was assassinated in
front of his Staten Island home
Wednesday night in a stunning gangland
hit that recalled some of the most
infamous Mafia killings in city history
Khali was shot several times and run
over in front of his mansion in the
lavish Todd Hill neighborhood at about
9:20 p.m. his wife and young children
were inside priests sources told the
post the gunman sped off in a blue
pickup truck after the hit which one
source described as quote disrespectful
because it took place near his family
home in an outer borough Kali is the
first mob boss to be slain in New York
since a fresh-faced John Gotti ordered
the murder of then Gambino boss Paul
Castellano in 1985 at sparks steakhouse
in Midtown so this is like the biggest
mob hit in over 30 years no Jackie you
come to me no that's all I know crazy
really crazy like this is the stuff that
movies are made of totally and I feel
like there's been I mean not that I keep
up on mob news but it's it seems pretty
quiet
Gambino such a name and he was like The
Godfather of the Gambino clan of the
Fenton one of the five families I
understand I watch The Godfather so it's
a big deal they're both very sad at the
end of the day a child lost her father
so that's it and apparently done in a
very disrespectful way outside his home
because apparently it's more respectful
to murder someone in Manhattan than it
is in the outer boroughs and no there's
like more rules they did it like they do
horrible evil things but like they have
a ton of respect for family like it
makes no sense
no it's makes yeah even God he had more
respect he did it out of Manhattan Kali
was rushed to Staten Island University
Hospital where he was declared dead a
9-1-1 caller reported hearing six or
seven shots at the scene but it was
unclear how many bullets struck cali i
mean look when your job is like being a
mobster like the price you pay this is
the price you pay and I was reading some
articles that he was a really quiet
it old-school boss he dealt in like the
oxycontin heroin biz terrible um but
that he was like low-key about it okay
but it's like how do you know that
someone's a mob boss but then they're
like it's like it's the New York Post
and the police and everyone like they
knew that a mob boss died but it's like
doesn't mob imply criminal activity like
how are they right but then you need the
proof yeah and I guess him being low-key
like he helps him with the proof I mean
I don't know a lot of this story but I
look forward to seeing the movie about
it me too you know who's gonna play
Frankie he's 53 oh that's not old
Bradley Cooper no like I feel like it
needs to be like a saggy like Robert
Downey jr. yeah George Clooney he's
older than that
you need actually and they need someone
break from New York I was sitting at the
accent right
yeah leo perhaps some queens perhaps
we'll see uh so yeah I just thought that
was an interesting story it's like the
biggest mob killing in years and those
things like our big news and also what
we were just watching Molly's game and
remember when she gets like hit on her
by the mob because she won't like give
them a cut of her business that was soso
and then she's like in her apartment
afraid to leave like ready for the call
to come or chefs like give over cut and
then she sees in the newspaper like a
story like this is what she saw right
that's true
somewhere someone who was waiting for a
call from Frank Ali like didn't get it
today right like a life could have been
potentially saved right and also because
even if they have other like the mob
still runs even though the head is dead
but now they're gonna be focused on who
the [ __ ] was in this blue pickup truck
no one also like who becomes the new mob
dad like how Michael Corleone we got it
even though he was the youngest son yeah
because that other son was out of
control yes honey and then the other one
was like right dead right
I only saw Godfather one in I'm not so
but well-versed with The Godfather I
know it's very confusing cuz all the
names are so similar like Bartoli and
bazolar in each Leone
yeah it's confusing but all I know is
there was a console you Audie Tom there
was a counselor des Nietzsche and Tom it
turns out counselor snitches and my boss
imagine she was good at it um she would
be good at it cuz she's just like
stubborn and I just didn't know the
things like this like we're still going
on mm-hmm
well they weren't a power it's been
really quiet but I'm but my dad
okay with you that's okay I just like I
did something like really brave and I
look when I was ordering new jeans I got
her to size smaller because I thought
I'd like had lost much weight but she
fell thinking I haven't oh so much
better
I finally weighed myself today for the
first time since my wedding and I've
been really good like since I've been
home for six days now since Utah and I
was like mentally prepared to see a
certain number and since my wedding we
only needed two pounds well but I don't
feel that way like I can see I look in
the mirror you you know you look good I
look the same I don't know I forgot a
little but whatever I'm back I'm back on
my [ __ ] and back back in the New
York ooh well you know it'll help with
are you cooking more at home filling in
your New Year's resolution with all your
new registry where yes I'm learning I'm
cooking more at home I'm using a lot of
honestly being like toast partner
sponsors with a lot of really great
brands that make it easy for me to cook
at home and I have I'm doing a cooking
class boot camp in April three classes
and I send you the link you know I'm not
into that coz i'm i'm with hella fresh
now i'm a little fresh ambassador
therefore I don't need your little
cooking classes it's so cute no
hellofresh has made it really easy for
me but it's like I can only cook what
they're giving me rich I'm loving but I
want to even get better at the things
that they're that they're sending me so
hello fresh is fresh pre-measured
ingredients and easy-to-follow six-step
pictured recipe cards they're delivered
to your door each week in a special
insulated box you spend less time meal
planning a grocery shopping so you can
get that time back to doing more of what
you love I have done it now a couple
times and they give you different
options like vegetarian just specific to
your dietary needs and restrictions you
know I'm very heat of season I have lots
of dietary needs and restrictions so for
80 dollars off your first month of
hellofresh go to hello fresh calm /
toast 80 enter code toast 80 so that's
$80 off your first month of hello fresh
at hello fresh calm / toast 80 and enter
code toast 80 I have now been I've been
on how the fresh I've done it like three
or four times and it's like nice when
Ben comes from from like his actual jobs
like be like a nice why why I embrace my
inner like 50s housewife but then I like
make him do the couple dishes that there
are that's perfect that's fair yeah he's
down it's like it's always like there
are dishes who's walking Theo and who's
doing the dishes and I always rather
walk so yeah very fair sounds like you
run a fair house um and I
Democracy Now teacher och receipt well
been used to say we did a podcast
episode awhile ago when I said been
realistically like in your mind what
percentage of household chores do you
believe we contribute to and he had the
gall to say twelve and I do feel now
he's definitely at 12 percent but back
then he was like a hard three okay fair
yeah exciting
speaking of criminal activity it's a
very crime heavy show today it is I
guess it's a crime heavy world we live
in so sad Laurie Lachlan released on 1
million dollar bond after court
appearance full house sir Larry Lachlan
appeared in federal court on loss and in
Los Angeles Wednesday over her alleged
role in the nationwide college bribery
scandal she was released after posting 1
million dollar bond
Lachlan 54 in her fashion design her
husband massimo jia newly are facing
mail fraud charges for allegedly paying
$500,000 to bribed their daughter's way
into USC as bogus crew athletes the
actress said nothing in the courtroom
other than responding yes to magistrate
judge steve kim's questions the judge
instructed her to limit her travel to
the continental US and also reluctantly
agreed to let her continue traveling to
vancouver canada for filming jian newly
the man behind the massimo t-shirt brand
if you are target customer you're
familiar with this name already appeared
in court Tuesday and was also released
on 1 million dollars bond
Lachlan had been in Vancouver but
returned to California Wednesday morning
where she was taken into custody so
there's two things that I'm still
confused about 1 the Frank Gallagher of
it all my figure I found out what ok ok
so Felicity Huffman and William H Macy
employed the services of this consultant
for their first daughter and as pretty
sure it was just olicity Huffman on the
emails that went through then they spoke
again to the pronoun the daughter they
wanted to use the services again they
were taught and William H Macy was on
emails they're deciding whether or not
to use the services and bribe college
admissions and they decided not to so
I'm the only email said he's on they
didn't actually go through with it which
I was watching daily pop and I believe
it was least they had Lisa bloom on you
know fainted he loved Lisa bloom we made
some interesting points and she said
that as if they were Felicity Huffman is
lawyer they would argue that she did it
the first time and she learned her
lesson she didn't do it again oh yeah
and I mean Felicity Huffman paid 15
grand like it's so different it's so
different now I'm confused where the mug
shots
no I feel like when any like Jessie
smell out and are Kelly's like they went
viral if you were released on bail that
means you were arrested yeah that means
you get a mug shot now I feel as if
there's even more special trip like
privileges being given because everyone
no matter who you are gets much shot
that's a really good question I don't
know there may be one of the toasters
will help us out but I don't think
there's any special treatment going on
here where's like Felicity Huffman was
arrested with guns the special treatment
is over
she was arrested with guns was I mean
like when when she was arrested at her
home like there were FBI agents they had
like loaded weapons like you know it's
just so weird like if you look at these
people like if you look at William H
Macy's like this old man like Harry
Lachlan ant that America's sweetheart
and Becky well I feel the justice system
moves so slow like we're not even gonna
really get it get a sentencing or
whatever for awhile
yeah I get I think it moves slow but
then it moves fast like things happen
but I think also sometimes the what's
the defendants they wanted to move slow
are Kelly right they want to drag it up
in a situation like this like if they
are innocent or they they have something
that could help them or save them they
would want it to move as quickly as
possible well so then a toaster did I
mean oh great service by tagging me in
this Twitter thread actually him to pull
it up because yesterday I was saying
like what's the big deal like the crime
doesn't fit the punishment mm-hmm
someone tagged me in the thread hold on
give me 10 seconds do-do-do-do-do-do
decided you know it was um excuse me did
she deliver you know it was helpful okay
what was the gist no I can't
paraphrase it because it's full of legal
jargon
ya know it's different um come on sorry
give me tell us what it said we're live
I'm sorry okay everybody at fasteners so
it was like three or four cases where
mothers had been sentenced to like 12 or
15 years in jail for the craziest thing
like this woman wanted her kid to go to
a public school in a different district
and she was
once and she said that she lived in a
certain district and like lied about it
I guess even though she was technically
homeless so like and they sent her to
jail yeah crazy okay what does that have
to do with this that people the justice
system is broken basically okay but it
doesn't really have to do like that's a
separate issue for justice to be served
like this actually totally oppened know
but it's situations where like mothers
were technically doing something illegal
for but they're so different but I don't
I don't get what the point of the thread
was actually but I don't know okay what
okay no I learned something I just can't
find it okay uh sure um so what you were
saying that a lot of new information has
come out about this story since well I'm
just like seeing more stuff you know
Mike I don't know that olivia jade was
on a yacht and then he pulled her off me
she was on spring break in fact it was a
big-ass yacht
you know who's covering the story like
hardcore bar stool really they're doing
even like such a girls we're like here
are the hot girls who are the USC yeah I
know I saw their story it was like all
their bikini pictures I was like what
these girls are college students oh I'm
sorry thank you someone okay someone
this is a point that preferred was
trying to make the poor always get
unfair jail time oh so it's like if
these women who Tech did something a
whole lot more unethical don't get any
jail time when people who were doing it
for the same reasons they wanted better
things for their kids but they didn't
have access like they get 12 years in
jail
I agreed that's what it was thank you I
knew there was a point there so um and
it was like these women were homeless
just trying to get their kids in school
and they like lied that they lived on
the other side of town and they like
actually went to jail for that that's
crazy and I'm the one like first of all
that's injustice and that needs to be
taken care of but I agree that they
shouldn't get special treatment or even
because we were saying yesterday like
this is a non-violent crime like that
doesn't mean you don't go to jail like I
regretted and I like I said yesterday
literally I know a lot of people
disagreed with what we said yesterday
and every comment of people are like
saying something I literally agree with
what everyone is saying and I also agree
on the other side like that it is sad
for these children and these are
families and at the end of the day like
all they wanted was better for their
children but at the expense of other
children and it's just the privilege
becoming more
right and being corrupt and you know
going through back doors when people
will go through the front door they get
chatter the point is that poor families
trying to get their kids into a better
district by flooding their addresses go
to jail but these people will most
likely get off and I don't know that's
where the injustice is and I didn't even
know that like you go to jail for lying
about your district the government is
like such losers like taking themselves
so seriously so and like okay maybe you
can be arrested for lying about your
district but like jail time in 12 years
jail time right like also I watched
Friday Night Lights were like one of the
kids lied about where he was to get to
school with the East Dillon Panthers
like his mom didn't go to jail right
they put it like a mail box there right
yeah interesting interesting
I mean at this point again like Joe
Giudice I would be more surprised if
they don't go to jail because if like
Maureen Laughlin's crime is like she
could face like up to 21 years so even
one year that would be a that would be a
favorable sentencing you know right of
course because if you look at people in
similar scenarios who are from different
backgrounds home girl went to jail for
12 years right yeah no I totally agree
so I don't know where I stand I mean
look this in the Kevin Hart thing I'm
right in the middle I see a both sides I
just I hate when the world comes for
everyone like no matter what you did
like there are very few people who
deserve like Hitler deserves canceled
culture you know I mean right so it's a
horrible feeling so I always like
automatically feel empathy for the
person who's being cancelled but at the
end of the day you did something wrong
and you deserve whatever punishment that
is agreed agreed and we'll be following
this story I mean I hope they like
cameras into the courtroom because also
I think the defense is here because it
is kind of murky like what they knew
what they didn't know how what level of
and I think each case in each family was
different in terms of what they new
level of involved was criminal activity
and it seems like this consultant to
like wore a wire and like literally
spilled all the beans the cops probably
like just couldn't sleep at night yeah
and by the way how long does this go
back for cuz I feel like these are just
the most recent ones yeah but like you
know Laurie Lachlan got his name from
someone who got his me from somewhere
exactly 4 OCT
if Trevor Noah made a joke and I guess
we have the same sense of humor he was
like why don't these kids just get in
the old fashioned way and donate a
library yeah that's a mechanic is that
okay right but that doesn't make any
sense like there is a way of buying your
way into college
legally every every rich family does it
every building every school is named
after some family so why go this route
which is like the obviously more
unethical route right like there's like
poison Gary this was a guarantee whereas
if you if you donate a library it's not
guaranteed right it's like unspoken like
we'll let your kid in me right but they
might not get in but I mean what's it's
and then it says at the end of day the
worst case scenario you donate a library
your kid doesn't get in okay your kid
didn't get into the college that you
wanted them to go to that's just not the
end of the world and I just can't state
enough how little college matters for
everyone but also for people like who
are never gonna get jobs like did the
people that were being shoved into these
schools unfairly like they didn't need
to be in these schools like they're
gonna work and become an actor or
whatever and just live off the the fruit
of their parents labor right and Lee
simply was saying and on the one hand
cuz we were saying yesterday that you
know this is parents doing anything for
their kids you can imagine you would do
anything for your kids but Lee saloon
was saying like this is bad parenting at
its finest first of all like not not
making your kids achieve anything but
then they get you know all this glory
and second of all a lot of these
instances the kids thought they were
getting these scores for real it's like
you think you're smarter than you are
and that will never that will not help
you in life and a great point and then
by the way you get into a school that
you're not that you you academically not
fit for what happens when you've entered
a disability so just so hard when you do
get in based on Mary like if you're not
there's a reason why there's an
admissions process because some people
can't hack it right that will cause like
more depression and anxiety and like
stress for these kids and they should go
to a college that they're terrified for
and then betsy layne they just made a
great point in the comments the
difference between going about it in the
way of like donating a building or is
just like selfishly bribing someone is
at least that building benefits other
people like there's now a place for
someone to sit with their computer and
whatever but going about the way is just
like mocking crew team photos you're
benefiting absolutely nobody but
yourself and you're actually putting
other people out of disadvantage like
people who could have been
those students very true and also if you
go to a college that you're not worthy
for but the building the library is in
your name like your fellow students will
know like why you're here right as
opposed to thinking oh wow this you know
this excellent crew member right a right
standing member there's a building named
after you like everyone whispers about
you in the library like right oops -
girl that's what that my library was
called I mean there was like worse
things to be said about you lately he
only got in here cuz she donated a
library right uh yeah and why is it
always a library I don't know like what
about this science what was the Colgate
library called case case guy er maybe it
was to family totally and then the
Science Center was called a hoe you know
I don't even know if there was a mall
I'd never set foot in the Science Center
I don't even know if it exists I'm well
there was the I was I hang out a lot in
the center for global and academic
something well then it doesn't sound
like it has a name on it so that should
be your dream this to me has to be the
name no there was silver all the
buildings that names on them
the stern school business sign art yeah
and it's like crazy how you use call it
sir and I'm going to NYU Stern and then
you don't realize that that's a family
name written there's like a stern
running around campus you know there's a
lot of Stern's running around totally
interesante well I'm going to Kuwait
next weekend because they did invited me
to speak so if you're a Colgate student
by the way I'm gonna be doing like a
private session on Friday well you are
we what day uh next Friday so I won't be
on but um anyway so I was oh so I'm
excited to hear about like you know what
are people saying on campus right I
wonder what the discourse is on the
college campuses cuz college campuses
these days are always having you know
dialogues and [ __ ] and also college
campuses are really like hotbed hotbed
grounds for issues that are big in the
country that then get centralized
whether it's like sexual assault right
because you have all these people coming
from all around the world with different
life experiences small country it's a
microcosm yeah and it's so interesting
that's actually a great point I'm sure
Colgate just glad that they're not
involved in that totally I definitely
feel like NYU does not have their hands
clean in this whole thing they're always
like you know NYU owns the most real
estate in New York yes
like more than any development and NY
real estate company is actually the
wealthiest University because of all the
land that they write it's like the most
anyway you definitely gives me [ __ ]
especially with all the celebrities that
go there like then I'll get in like for
real no but you know then they're
extracurriculars of being like an uptown
girl that helps what's up Kota fanny oh
ya know they have great press yeah being
except one mistake they made is not
being involved in SVU because SVU refers
to Hudson University and it definitely
means to be NYU but I do wonder why they
didn't get their branding in there it's
a little disappointing but I love that
there's a fake College out there called
Hudson you know that it's NYU but it's
probably because like who wants to be
like talk you know that's just not a
good look for them or like students are
getting murdered
totally we're like oh I guess that's
true yeah it's always like a bad
sorority hazing right yeah no college
wants to be part of that I mean I would
do anything to be a part of us for you
did I tell you once the guys I had an
audition for to be an extra on SVU I
don't think you did because I tried to
make you tell so many times but you said
you couldn't for some reason well they
told me at first not to talk about it
even though you didn't get it cuz like
you know maybe you'll get the next one
but like I never heard back from them so
like whatever yes I was adjusting for
the role of a young girl from Pensacola
I was a murderer I I had like a very ill
cancer stricken mother who I had to like
change her diapers I live you killed an
Instagram in and I killed an Instagram
influencer cuz I was jealous over I was
a little offended that they didn't ask
me to play like the beautiful Instagram
influencer I had to play like the
heinous farm girl and you know it was a
blessing that I didn't get it cuz the
girl who played it was [ __ ] great I
saw the episode and I like knew some of
the lines because they gave me two
scenes to memorize she's from she's from
Pensacola it's not much bigger than
Maysville
it was very chummy moment I thought it
was because I was being cross-examined
understand I was in the audition I was
like have you ever had your father date
someone your own age it was very shiny
uh everyone was gonna go fine and then
while an order episode like did come out
that is an episode now and it could have
been Claudia you guys should watch it
the girl did a good that was last season
yeah that's hilarious
okay are we all good on college Cate I'm
sure we'll talk about it tomorrow and I
mean it's a developing story you were
gonna say I wonder if they're gonna let
news cameras and they have decided to
let news cameras into justice bullets um
hearing which I will be tuning in like I
remember when we were in camp and they
keep in a while since we've had like a
big court when we were in camp a long
time ago the Casey Anthony trial was on
TV and I wasn't like it I wasn't old
enough and didn't really know what was
going on but my
Madison who was a year older than me she
was like tuning in every day am i [ __ ]
what are you watching she the Casey
Anthony oh she's from Florida that's why
she was really invested so now I'm just
like I'm ready to get invested in a
courtroom like OJ tech thing yeah and
honestly we have to be if we're gonna
talk about it like we have to know all
the facts and it's hard to keep up with
but we'll do it for you yeah and we
might net we now might have like to
crime like it's like an O J situation
you know no I mean there's our Kelly
there's Lori Loughlin and there's Jesse
Jesse Smollett I know her last name is
now pronounced Laughlin apparently but I
refuse I'm still with the Laughlin yeah
I'm trying to like make it Lachlan like
it's like you could hear either you know
I want to hear from the rest you know
what who I want to hear from on this hmm
I might I just had the same in my head
what the same give me a second like who
is it I can help you Uncle Jesse what's
his name Oh John Cena John Stamos yeah
yeah I want to hear from him why my
amnesia is bad today sorry okay fifth
and final story before we got into real
houses New York recap Priyanka Chopra
gives the perfect response to exes Nick
Jonas and Miley Cyrus DEA each other
okay back story if you don't follow my
least iris on Instagram recently missing
out she has been posting premium content
of the glory days I'm talking like oh
five OH six seven things you know
Disney Channel filming at Pepperdine
University what's that song called it's
just one spark starts by the earth raise
your heart with your hand just one spark
starts a fire with one little action the
chain reaction will never stop singing
song shine a light and send it home
so she's posting photos from the Gloria
he's basically saying like women we
cannot get along I guess she was
inspired by International Women's Day so
now she's posting all throwbacks of her
with every girl she's ever been rumored
to feed with Taylor Swift Demi Lovato
Selena Gomez it was honestly epic I
realize that's why she was doing it that
it was all people she was rumored to be
to have been feuding with or just like
people from that era she posted the
stand up to cancer video and and which
is everyone on saige Beyonce Natasha
baby CL Rihanna I was in love with that
performance for a million reasons but
when Miley posted it I loved her she
kept Nicole Scherzinger in it because
Nicole Scherzinger cannot sing the whole
thing is really weird and it's like at
that it's weird how in that video and
out that time of her life like Miley
couldn't sing and now she can like she
was like literally very nasally what's
the song with things getting mad at you
I'll be Rihanna obviously I have lots of
soul in my voice things get better
things through whatever I don't Lana
totally that's actually really good
that's what she sounds like
but now she is like one of the most
amazing voices of our time yeah I think
she like got really far obviously being
Billy Ray Cyrus's kid but like the show
got so far cuz she did have like a fine
voice but then when she really started
to focus on music and she wasn't in a
Disney Channel machine like she really
developed boys and I think the backyard
sessions were really the most you know
ground breaking for her creatively yeah
so anyways premium content at she's
posting and just saying like let's all
get along she's tagging Rihanna people
that she is friends with is and friends
with etc and Nick Jonas DM tur like
saying that these throwbacks have been
fired and then she posted a video of her
dancing to seven rings saying that
moment when even your ex knows your
socials have been flamed and then she
swipes up to a screenshot of the d-ends
and then so Priyanka misses Jonas chimed
in on fun
she wrote lol hahaha hubby is right
these posts are flame emoji okay
honestly I'm not ever gonna add shame
anyone but like she's really showing her
age just with that comment like haha
like it was weird and it's like that's
how you text someone when you are mad
right it's like you are great no that's
like a satirical thing they would you
want to know when they're trying to play
a 12 year old your ello
hahaha like one of those was uh yeah
yeah I used to love that little carrot
top what's that yeah I don't know if
she's actually enjoying this um so like
I don't think I don't think Miley Cyrus
him and Nick Jonas are threatening it no
no but anything that gets in Nick and
Priyanka back into People magazine's
like weekly roundup Priyanka is down for
interesting factoid that I saw on daily
pop I guess Priyanka is coming out with
a YouTube show relatable wait Jackie I
guess that technically puts us in the
same industry as Priyanka Chopra
so I guess wait where rocket chop were
related to Deepak Chopra unclear it was
like Cohen for Jews you know it's just
like everyone has LS Amy yeah and I
think like we would know and maybe like
he would be on her YouTube channel but
it's her interviewing fellow actresses
like about life so it's like us
interviewing fellow thirst monsters
right and it's like what can I learn
from a fellow ther so answer I don't
know it's giving me very Inside the
Actors Studio vibe it is she wears like
it's gonna be like you know what
inspires you truly those are gonna be
the question second question for you
mmm-hmm what inspires you um I mean it's
a it's like this dumbest and hardest
question of all time because like I'm
really inspired by nothing I'm inspired
by myself but I'm also inspired by like
the way that like I feel sometimes when
I'm excited about something and I'm
inspired to have that feeling more
that's so funny because I always say but
I'm not gonna interview I'm like you can
ask me anything but I just don't ask me
what inspires me and then when like I do
get asked that I say nothing inspires me
I inspire myself and that's literally
what you just said because like I'm
trying to think but like I'm trying to
give you a stranger thank you inspire me
because I know that question is a joke
you know right that nobody's actually
inspired I sometimes feel motivated
which is very different than it's
finding like I never look at anyone like
an inspiration like I'm inspired by
serving justice and like having you know
like telling like truthful stories on
art and getting the word out I know
whose it inspires me um rivers well
obviously she gets me out of bed in the
morning but I know who actually like as
a woman inspires me Judge Aqua Lena oh
yeah
the Larry national court judge did you
thought you were going to thank Judge
Judy her to but actually I was watching
Judge Judy mess yesterday because she'll
change the channel
isn't who inspires me because I could be
inspired by others as well as myself
it's what inspires you yeah that's true
which is a worse question just music
inspires someone had a nice new music
inspires me to hearing the song like a
mood of a song that inspires me to get
it done sometimes in your a song I'm
like okay I'm going for a jog maybe your
goals and dreams inspire inspire you but
still that's me inspiring myself with
really goals and dreams it's just like
such a lame question but who inspires
you who inspires me oh great question
Joan Rivers really I always think what
was young you know the picture of Joan
Rivers like in the background we really
need to start getting on like our
bookshelf flow and start like keeping
all the things people give us and like
memento and like the 600 page letter
that Stephen McGee brought and also a
picture of Joan Rivers our gossip
channel threw it away we didn't talk
about that we were mention tracking I
saw your Instagram story I didn't watch
watch opens live because I don't watch
summer house because I prefer to only
watch shows that aren't trash but when
you and so I didn't watch summer house
Kyle on the show on my trumpets live but
and it also wasn't here when Stephen
hosted so when he referenced our show on
watch happens live as a gossip channel
first of all like is that English I'm
not sure I guess technically we are a
gossip channel also I mean he could have
given us a shout-out but maybe he really
just didn't know that it was the toast
and he did come on the breath ones and
I'm just glad he didn't say this bread
no it felt very um real he did not
remember our name lucky and he might not
have even known that it was us like I
feel very certain about that yeah and
it's fine because like we know and you
guys know and and we know that you know
that he knows um and I felt seen you
know and it's like how many times is
someone gonna like bring us up
inadvertently on Morton toes before and
he's like well it's gonna get weird so I
love trolling the toasters groups just
like you know on the weekends and
somebody did mention that they went to
AC too which is any Covenant Anderson
Cooper's tour and they do a Q&A portion
and somebody stood up and was like would
you ever do a daytime show on Bravo like
the girls in the morning shows like
would be perfect for it and he goes
what's the morning shows and she's
hosted by girls no job Jackie O sisters
they love Bravo they recap everything
and he goes I don't girl with no job she
bartender on my show Wow wait he is so
many bartend I never saw that one either
he says let's do a mom once asked him at
AC to would you ever do he was they were
like I'm a big fan of Maureen toast like
five people cheering would you ever do a
morning show on
and he said a morning show I do not
think would work on Bravo
[ __ ] okay we'll do it we'll do a mid mid
afternoon but it makes sense because the
way that so many people watch the show
and the people who watch our show watch
it from work on their phones and it's
like no you're not going to a TV and
turning on Bravo at 10:30 you know
honestly the best I think platform for
this show obviously besides the way it
is now and it's perfect and if it stays
like this forever I really don't care
but it's like if Bravo had a streaming
service or if like if NBC you comes out
with one which I believe that they are
with like all their programming they had
a live morning show so that because the
part the reason why this show is
successful is because you don't need TV
to watch it like it's cool to put it on
your Roku but and then the day you could
listen to this on the coming the train
on bus and a car playing two screens at
work right if you're a podcast listener
so the accessibility is what makes it
relatable and accessible for everyone so
that was definitely accessibility is
what makes it accessible so interesting
factories that are interesting yes so
that's what Bravo would need to do if
they partnered with us mm-hmm but oh my
god I hadn't thought about this college
cheating scandal I just thought of you
know what's a roundabout way they could
have gotten around this whole thing if
they just send up for Skillshare totally
I'm on Skillshare
take a man taking the mobile photography
class but like all the girls if they
could have just like I don't know gotten
their share is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fill your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration so I'm
taking a mobile photography one and
actually got snitch on a social media
marketing class because I just feel as
our intern it would only behoove her to
learn more about the industry that we
currently live in life all of the very
wise lifelong learning important to you
my phone learning is important to me
because I hosted prestigious morning
show and of course warned that I'm able
to part wisdom on people and also
important that I'm able to make graphics
for our social media channels which I'm
learning on Skillshare yeah because
Jackie is so I like text me every time
she need a graphic like for a guest card
on my [ __ ] got on Skillshare
getting a social media marketing class
and learn how to make a Gascon okay I'm
a social media marketer I can actually
teach a class but I need a photoshopping
class yeah so join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today but the special offer just for our
listeners you get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right skill
shares offering our listeners of the
morning toast two months of unlimited
access to over 25
classes for free so to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash morning toast
again that Skillshare comm slash morning
toast to start your two months now
Skillshare comm slash morning chose to
two months free don't bribe your way
just go to Skillshare university
seriously um and it's free
save yourself five hundred grand and
plus the cost of tuition it's like
tuition on top of that right a room
aboard right it's a go plan i used to
love being on a meal plan oh my god i
used to swipe that [ __ ] anyway it was
probably like one of the only schools in
the country that has as big and dynamic
of a kosher cafeteria because like all
jewish people live in New York and not
only that it was a [ __ ] scene like
you wanted to be seen I usually do my
hair to go to the kosher CAF and like so
Monday Wednesday Fridays it was a meet
meals and then Tuesday Thursdays it was
dairy and dairy was like not as late cuz
like right what are gonna have like a
girl cheese okay and like kosher dairy
is not yeah but like the meat tastes
like hot boys were there I used to come
from work so I'm like 12:00 to 1:30 like
it was a [ __ ] scene like you couldn't
get a seat like I know a lot of people
who like met their boyfriends and
husbands like in the [ __ ] kosher CAF
and for short we call it the cake half
and I actually my first year in the dorm
like lived in the building that the KCAP
was in so I felt like very a part of the
community very cool yeah I was never
really like enjoying a meal plan cuz all
I used to eat in college was like
special Kate bars in candy you know and
like I don't need to be a special kay
bars were the [ __ ] they're really good
well there was one year I didn't do a
meal plan because I lived in the dorms
for one year and then like to save money
in sanity I just moved home cuz I lived
in New York um and I commuted from home
so I didn't really need a meal plan
because that was never on campus for
meals like except lunch and like okay
I'll buy a sandwich but I really missed
the meal plan the experience and you
know what and when you used to have this
thing I don't think they have it anymore
we're like participating businesses in
the area like nail places fresh and co
diners they used to used to be able to
pay with NYU dollars yeah so it's like I
didn't have any money but like I would
get like meal plans for my tuition and I
would like use that money like to get
manicures it's like honestly like a
Ponzi scheme in itself 100% you do
American greed on it I've been watching
American it's so interesting I watched
one yesterday about a money manager to
the Stars his name was Ken Starr and he
like just blew all of this money and
spent it all on his stripper wife like
why aren't there movies about
all of these things and then I watched
one that was about a 9/11 fraud like
someone taking image of a 9/11 Widow and
like it was honestly like so horrifying
horrifying and like sad and it wasn't
even enjoyable because I was like like
there the guy like there's a lot of con
men and comment are bad people but the
lawyer who was talking was like cut even
konma and have a moral code and it's
like even most some common wouldn't take
advantage of a 9/11 Widow yeah this guy
that's like the the what are the calls
oh my god I'm having like a blackout
brain today the gangs what does it call
it mobs
they have a moral code really weird it's
like yes it's it's also like war there's
certain things you can't do in war right
I think or it's like shooting someone
from behind it's like you're still gonna
shoot someone but yes right Jess stone
used to shoot animals from behind no
that's why he was a real beast he didn't
have a moral code is that fair he
doesn't care no and then he literally
got the beast from behind Oh Mike you're
brown shadow he didn't care that it
wasn't fair when I just sneaked up on my
quiver and beasts of the field same
prayer then I carefully aim for the
liver then I shoot from behind there I
don't care did you see that guy's drone
without buckingham palace with a mile
clooney and Clooney Josh what's the same
Josh Pastner Jeff yeah Josh mister
gazook you know Luke Evans yes and also
a Josh Hartnett was there you know Josh
Hartnett is like a name that I know
Buckingham Palace what's his name
Benedict Cumberbatch he's out of control
buckingham thank you every time I do
this I feel like [ __ ] Kim and Kyle
Richards yelling at Brandi Glanville
they said I wasn't doing crystal meth in
the bathroom you owe us an apology
Jackie made us when we were in Utah
every night we were watching movie we
watched Bohemian Rhapsody which [ __ ]
had a lot of thoughts on we watched
that's where that's crazy rich Asians
the best movie I ever saw and we watched
whiplash and Jackie was begging us to
watch Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy mostly
because she liked the name and she was
running around the house being like
Tinker Tailor she made us watch it a
list we went through all the best and
Oscar movies cuz we also it was fresh
off the heels of the Oscars we watch
Green Book what else did we
buck was the best movie I ever saw you
asked any other we watched Bohemian
Rhapsody what I voted to watch Oscar we
wanted too much good mood early went
through the oscar list over the past 30
years of movies that have been nominated
for Best Picture Mimi and we made a list
of ones that we would watch and was fine
Olivia saw it and said it was the best
movie she ever saw and I was like okay
so it's a good incredible movie and it's
Tinker Tailor and I couldn't stop saying
it and we watch the trailer and the
trailer actually looked really good and
interesting and everyone was saying I
was me and Margo we're very against it
very against it it was like a spy movie
the trailer made it look interesting
there's Tom Hardy there's Buckingham
comer Matt and the whole thing is like
who's the spy who's the tinkerer who's
the sailor right and we put it on after
days of me running on a housing Tinker
Tailor me and Margo were sitting behind
Jackie and like literally within 10
minutes we left and like nobody realized
it was nobody realized because I fell
asleep
it was so bad and the first 10 minutes
every movie you need some time to get in
to read you know what other movie that
we watched I was an Oscar contender the
Melissa McCarthy movie could you ever
forgive me at least that one was weird
but kept me hooked slightly at least I
understood what they were saying right
yeah I was in Old English everyone look
the same so I didn't know who was the
soldier who was the spy I couldn't I
couldn't so who ended up being the spot
I didn't well I didn't finish it I fell
asleep and then like I had to call it
quit was it was so hard for me to so you
admit no something you want to say to me
and Margo yes much like you were wrong
about Hannah B being a good Bachelorette
I was wrong about Tinker Tailor being a
good movie well you're so Lisa
Vanderpump right now right it's like I
can't admit that I was wrong without
telling you that you're also wrong can
we talk about the guys they released all
the pictures of the guys for Hannah be
Tinker Tailor DiIorio Taylor Swift they
released all the guys for Hannah be in
it's like I didn't look at it I don't
care about the guys because I'm actually
I'm while I might watch the first
episode just to get a taste of how the
seasons gonna go I'm really not watching
the season like I'm really done however
I think it was interesting that they
released the guys because that's what we
already Steve does and they're trying to
put him on business really because I
feel like they definitely fuel his fire
I think they like him they're always
using him to start [ __ ] I think they
like him because it's like all press is
good press but when he's spoiling the
season and I think now every year more
and more people read spoilers and read
reality Steve and get on the internet
and there's actually I've gone and
different to watch it knowing who wins
and you you have a more like unbiased
view and you get to see like the
manipulation right
so I think they're trying to get ahead
of it just it was a weird move like when
they announced rate so Lindsay was about
to wreck while she was still on next
season they wanted to beat reality C
like they wanted to get ahead of
spoilers and so they're spoiling
themselves again which I think in this
case actually makes sense because nobody
cares who the guys are so it like you're
taking away cliques from reality C which
is great for you and you're also not
really spoiling anything because even if
you look at the cast photos we looked at
Coulson's cast photos and we were like
damn these girls are busted it turned
out to be like the most beautiful
qualified women well because the way
that it looks
it's like those they scrape the bottom
of the barrel for these guys the last
picture was a guy who looks like Tim
Tebow and honestly like I have high
hopes for him okay maybe other than that
like it wasn't one memorable face if
literally one of those guys came and sat
on my face I wouldn't know except the
one blonde one because he looks like
Kody the husband from Sister Wives who
has four wives and is the greatest show
fake Nick Miele
yeah of course and also every season
when I say like I'm not gonna watch a
season with it for whatever reason it is
I remember even Beca season I was like
kind of over it but then we met Colton
Underwood and I fell in love with him as
my brother-in-law he reignited the flame
inside us that so desperately yearns for
The Bachelor and that carried me through
paradise and to his season like I got
what I wanted of course I'm watching
Colton season but I just feel now like I
don't she'll be a fine season and she
seems like a super cute girl and I'm
sure one day we'll be friends with her
you know meet her at Coachella and then
what we'll want to delete this episode
cuz they said mean things right um
so wait can you tell me what goes on now
so they're gonna go film so we have a
break they start filming on Saturday and
then the season premiere is a second two
weeks in May like great we get a break
yeah but yet break we got our Mondays
back what should we do should we start a
mahjong Club um we still made up rules
but yeah but no it's like we should go
to sew house cuz 50% off [ __ ] yes I've
been there and so long that's always the
complex in the summer when like paradise
is airing and Bachelorette it's like you
want to go to so house for discount but
um you have to work well go to the spa
maybe he hit the discount um okay honey
so I watch Real Housewives of New York
this morning and I just have to say like
there are a lot of shows where nothing
happens and it's like boring and I hate
it but I just love the New York
housewives so much that even when
nothing happens I still really enjoy the
episode I have that with Vanderpump
rules - like they haven't given us
anything in weeks
I also watch Anna from pearls so he
could recap that as well but they
haven't given us anything in weeks but
I'm still enjoying because I just love
people and I really feel this like
kindred spirit towards Bethany and my
problem thus far I'm loving the
brunettes versus the blonds it's so
funny and I'm Stan formerly on the side
of the brunettes of course um I have
such a big problem with Dorinda and it's
the same problem that I had from last
year it's just that she really gets away
with so much and she has such poor
behavior and the women just kind of like
enable her and I think it's a really
good thing that she's not drinking yeah
and I don't know if now in real life
that's still true I've heard that it's
not it's not even if you see the preview
for the season like she's clearly going
back in ha ha right but I have a really
big problem with the fact that a lot of
these women definitely have unhealthy
relationships with alcohol and there's
only one of them who's actively doing
something about it and like yes LuAnn
failed and had to go back to me a but
like that is a humbling thing and she's
open about it and she talks about
recovery a lot and she's trying she's
there's something to be said for someone
who's trying and the women are so mature
about it they were mean to her about it
the first time she went to rehab and now
again they don't even try and help her
at all and I just think it's like so
mean-spirited I agree and I think that
is a great point and you have to commend
her for trying but I also feel like
something she's still like glazing over
a lot of the issues and I think that's
why the women get frustrated with her
but it's like Dorinda was her best
friend when she was glazing over the
most glossing over Tom glazing over the
cheating still getting married still
like glaze seasoned glazed doughnut
right and now it's like she's actually
taking a lot of accountability for her
for the countess and okay she still
glazes over with some of the minor
details but okay it's better than
nothing and now it's like that she can't
stand for a right I need to talk about
the mermaid outfits because all those
girls look so skinny no like it's New
York and Beverly Hills it's like every
time they go on vacation or like get in
bathing suits like each body's better
than the next it's like Tinsley is tiny
yeah but like okay that that I expected
like Mona Mona 62 years old looks better
she looked amazing like I was really
like my jaw hit the floor to wring that
looks amazing Sonya looks amazing it was
incredible and I need to know like how
much I need a percentage like from
23andme like how much is genetics and
how much is dr. Sherin easy right cuz if
it's a lot dr. Shah anything that I'm
okay the tennis was so funny I'm when
Tinsley obviously was like so good at
tennis
like if Tinsley Mortimer can't play
Kenneth then who can not me it was
giving me very red oaks vibes you know
like with the
skort and then the brunettes barbers I
was really interested in like Barbara's
financials that's a nice house but she
lives there the decor was horrible you
mean barb the Builder Oh cute exactement
good me a company name or something like
Bob the Builder is that her company name
no it should be like Bob the Builder
Bart I did it and they keep saying but
she's a builder and I'm sorry but I
don't know a lot about the construction
industry so it's an industry I should
get into but what does that mean that
she's a builder she's market a developer
like is she she's actually very
successful and he's not a hard thing you
can get was a huge piece on her and the
times today and she's like a contract
developer real estate like she not only
she like buys and sells but also
develops the buildings that she buys I
think so why don't they say she's
developer I don't know the Builder is a
weird word and like I it's a weird word
it's like not the actual occupation of
someone so I think she's a very high-end
contractor you think a contractor you
think of man in a plaid shirt with his
butt crack sticking out no but there's
hi like that like there's high-end
buildings like high-end things I don't
she's like a Joanna Gaines but not
design but she's the chip
exactly exactly her [ __ ] furniture
was horrible but the outside of the
house I was still impressed it's a huge
house her and Bethenny need to start a
show together good that house oh my god
that's a great idea that house that
Bethenny houses the inside like was
stunning stunning and that was the house
that [ __ ] Ramona was making fun of
south of the highway so it's a Gilmerton
Montauk Highway is like everyone lives
on Montauk Highway like it's it's like
fancy as [ __ ] she owns a very large
construction firm that's awesome and so
respectable and definitely like a man's
industry and so like she seems badass
but why did they just keep like why
don't they say that why don't you talk
about her business like I don't
understand what builder means thank you
were getting there I'll put this on this
I'm a builder right no I build
confidence in others I am a builder so
wait there was more that I wanted to
discuss in the promo for next week it
appears that Ramona says maybe the most
horrible thing she's ever said in the
history of the show and she said a lot
of fucked-up things what did she say
Dennis he wasn't a smart guy he was on
drugs oh right
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] first of all that's
just an incredibly dumb thing to say and
not true - to speak ill of the Dead
so soon after this person passed away
like holy [ __ ] I think of all the things
Ramana has ever said and she's really
like said some of the most Lobell your
weren't you out here doing softcore porn
or when they're on the Brooklyn Bridge
you'll never have it you're lonely
you're a loser you LOI there's always to
bethany by the way right she of all the
things I think this might be the worst
perhaps I have to see it it's not what I
was watching in previous in traffic week
staff walk into a room and like I was
literally being like just wait and I
couldn't even process but obviously we
need context but I just think holy [ __ ]
like how insensitive are you like
Bethenny's a but it seems like she
doesn't say it to that me she says it
about Dennis which is not any better but
at least Bethenny does not really deal
with it but that's your years and now
she'll hear it yeah and I hope that at
least one of the ladies reacts in a
normal way they're all like that group
of blondes I'm really surprised that
Tinsley's a part of it and I hope that
she makes her way over to the brunettes
because I think she's a little bit more
above it and it's actually weird Sonya
Sonya is in the middle when you think
about it
from where we are last season Sonya was
very firmly on Bethenny's side yeah and
very against the blondes like her she
was really out there fighting for
Bethenny Souter for her to stay at
Ramona sit her and Ramona have such a
design so she's going to have a bad
relationship
yeah her being there it's kind of
misplaced no but her lemona actually
make sense cuz her and Ramona are great
friends and it's like she didn't want
and Bethenny invited her to stay with
her and she probably should have stayed
with Bethenny but she didn't want to
impose right on someone who's going
through so much right so she'll see with
your friend Ramona even if it's like
with and then it just made for this
divide but Tinsley thinking okay think
about it like it since Lee still really
good friends with Carol because in that
case she can't be on the burn s so in
real life now I believe that toons and
Carol are not on good terms
I don't know back then what the
situation was so it makes sense that
Tinsley is not gonna like stay at
Bethany's or anything or even be
friendly with deafening ya know I almost
wish a little bit that carol was still
on the show just because last season was
so good because I felt so strongly in
the Bethany versus Carol thing and I
don't think it was done no and those
were the heads
those were the godfathers of the team of
those where is when the team leader of
the blondes bowed out we don't it's not
it now I guess it's LuAnn for Serena but
they're actually true friends that I
think they'll come back together
think they'll get past it but when it
was like two totally separate teams it
was easier to understand no totally and
I'm just really loving having the ladies
back anytime the housewives comes back
I'm like ready for the Hamptons like I
want to go get a house I didn't even
notice that this was the first season
without Carol to me it felt like it was
like we've already done a season without
Carol and now it's another scene you
know it wasn't her absence was not felt
whatsoever no but I was watching last
night they were playing reruns of like
three seasons ago when they had the
reunion at age Laurence and I watched a
tale and it's just it's really sad
because they were talking a lot about
the divorce and Bethany was just crying
she's like nobody I don't even talk
about it like it's such torture like I'm
being waterboarded and Carol was like
you don't even know like Carol's like he
facetimes Bethany and Beth things trying
to talk to Brandon and he'll [ __ ] put
the phone up against a wall like Carol
really knew that ins and outs more so
than anyone like she knew just as much
as Bethany and so for her to have like
turned in such a way like it makes it so
much more sad yes grace and to know that
like even in the dead like sometimes
friends fight and that's that's normal
and especially when you're on the
housewives but there are some things
that like you know what will bring you
back together in a certain way even like
Jill Zarin Bobby's death and yeah
brought Bethenny and Jill back together
right so we like did that when Dennis
died and like it seemed clear from
Twitter that Carol like maybe sent a
text maybe no not to Bethany but she
just like well we should well to
Dennis's family it was very it was very
weird until she clearly was not there
for her and like that is the death of
the friendship like there's no coming
back from that right that's so true like
things happen in life where like you put
everything aside like I don't care what
you said what you did like I'll be there
for you because the right person is the
worst thing that could happen and we
were once friends and that's what's
important I couldn't have our fight
isn't more important than like this
trash but I would have liked to see that
unfold on this season because we're
coming off the hills of Dennis's death
where Carol was basically absent for
Bethenny like that was a storyline in
and of itself right but every time they
bring up to em it's like I feel weird
I can't admit like he wasn't a part of
the show like he has a family his kids
I'm sure they hate it like and they
flashbacks like the two scenes he was on
I don't know I just feel weird about it
I don't feel I just feel sad and I don't
think that his family I don't think his
family hates it okay cuz and that it
seems like Bethenny like is always
talking to his daughter and I mean
Bethenny is the queen of being able to
separate her public life from her
private life like we've never even seen
Brynn and I think
the family were like Dennis's wannabe
she would take care of it she like it
wouldn't be an issue yeah but every time
she just like starts to talk to you
cries it's so sad that's true refresh
it's true grief yeah and you know the
day the week that Dennis died was a week
they were supposed to start filming and
I believe they postponed for three weeks
for Bethany so it's why they're all in
the Hamptons and it's freezing right
let's so funny they're all having like
outdoor parties and they're like it's
freezing yeah that's hilarious oh my god
and LuAnn jumping on the Swan and
getting her knees wet like I felt paying
for that because it's really cold out
there that clammy look Ramona is like so
[ __ ] shameless like showing up to a
party where she like technically was
disinvited and like but I have to be
honest like shameless yes but that is
the reason why she is the og of New
York's the only one on the show who's
been there since day one and never never
was in ratley's LuAnn was there for day
one onesie she taunted her got demoted
because she went to parties that she
wasn't invited to totally when she just
shows up with those neon green heels
yeah no she's hilarious she's hilarious
and angry sometimes she was below the
belt but like she goes up and down I was
watching that same thing where she was
horrible to Bethany softcore porn and
then she's in the in the pool and she
feels horrible yeah that's what it is
and it's like Dorinda and so funny
Barbara made the most acute observation
for a group of friends that she just ran
she said this is the biggest problem
it's like you have to be able to own
your [ __ ] and Dorinda will never ever
ever say I was wrong like you have like
LuAnn day has done stuff to Dorinda
turndowns jumps up to LuAnn Dorinda will
never be able to physically say I was
wrong
right and that's why they're wrong that
Tinker Tailor but but at least you could
say very because there's so many things
Dorian is obviously wrong about that
thing she said it was gonna get a mug
shot for it like that's mean and hurtful
you screaming Giovanni and then yelling
at well you're raised it at Luann's
afterparty you're wrong to like there
are things you're wrong for you have to
be able to take a step back and look at
your actions and be like okay I was
wrong here but I felt justified to say
this like I especially think the month
later when you've seen it play out on TV
and everyone else agrees that you were
wrong in those things so it's like yes
Ramona does crazy horrible evil things
but then like she has her moments where
she's like you know I'm gonna set a
30-minute alarm because sometimes they
come in like a bull in a china shop it's
like yes you do she learned so but it
seems like she still comes in like a
bullet
right but for jorinda there's none of
that remorse there's none of that
self-awareness and like that's why she
pisses me off because she gets away with
so much in so does Ramona but at least
every now and then at the Reunion
she'll own and by the way no one gets
called out more than Ramona even when
she's she owns it half of the time even
when she's not owning it everyone is
digging in on her
Bethenny caused her into the village
idiot once and the rindas a victim yeah
no it's crazy like Joey no really pisses
me off
I feel that I feel that wholeheartedly
and she's being so weird this season and
we must talk about the Tyler Perry of it
all oh my god I kept like even she can't
admit she's wrong and even even in an
apology she won't say from her own words
just sent a quote so when they sent the
quote I thought she definitely found
this thing on Instagram like screenshot
in it and like it was just whatever but
then when she said end quote Tyler Perry
I was dying now I have to say Tyler
Perry is a smart man he gave that guy
from the book Cosby Show at Trader Joe's
I will forever love Tyler Perry and no
no discredit towards him or the his
accomplishments but he's not really like
you know the literary genius of our time
a soothsayer speaking of the eyes I
thought it was definitely like an
unknown proverb ancient African proverb
like some Confucius yeah
Deepak Chopra [ __ ] Rihanna cos I love
her where did she find that um I do not
know I want to know I do not know so far
forgettable brainy quotes forgiveness
quotes brainy brainy quotes like what I
love how all the women had the exact
reaction I wanted them to like they were
like where it's like they're reading it
they're interested Tyler Perry oh that's
priceless
it was really funny that was like an
iconic moment every season and honestly
I hate to render but every season she
does give us something I make it nice
your vagina's like the Holland Tunnel
Tyler Perry will be something this year
like clip she's good for that she is
good for that and honestly it was a
curveball because LuAnn was speechless
yeah and there's nothing you can say
back to that what would you say someone
sent you that like you were in this
situation what would you say I think I
would I thought about I think I would
just write like agreed there's nothing
wrong with ever attend a competing quote
from like Judd Apatow or so that's
hilarious yeah I wonder like who does
Tyler Perry consider his biggest
competition well he's so many things so
it depends on the industry
a filmmaker he's an actor LED lights at
Judd Apatow like another filmmaker with
like a very distinct style Martin
Scorsese Steven Spielberg yes James
Cameron John James Cameron yeah actually
it's like he made his comedies also and
their hell uses the same actors and all
the Judd Apatow movie said you know if
it's Jenna have to have movie based on
like the characters in some of the jokes
and you know it's Tyler Perry movie
based on the actors and sometimes
there's five times at perry characters
right
i just thought that was funny that is
funny well we did two 90 minute shows in
a row Wow I mean because this was our
first show back together you and I no
guests since might like for three weeks
now cuz it's just been so [ __ ] busy
you know what I'm doing today
what are you doing a pole dancing class
oh I read a funny meme it's like but
it's a really good workout girls who do
pole dancing classes actually obviously
I'm doing it cuz like I want to you know
like have a snatched body but mostly
because I think it's just a good talent
to have and it was available on
classpass and I'm like you know what let
me try this out that's so exciting
that's what's good about class that's
like I never would have found I know
that a lot of gyms offer it but I'm not
a gym member yeah so class passing is
the only way that I can actually get
into a class I think and you're not
doing an elliptical so right you need to
do something interesting a friend maybe
a fellow pole dancer class Fest is an
all-access membership to over 15,000 of
the best gyms and fitness studios all
over the world you can go anywhere you
want when you want how you want class
passes everything you need to make
working out fun which is really easier
said than done you can try new workouts
and studios without commitment to paying
a single gym or overpaying for drop in
classes which is what my problem was
with pole dancing can your first month
free right now at class past comms slash
try slash toast
get this exclusive offer only available
at clasp ask.com slash try slash toast
for your first month free so I'm
enjoying it I will let you know how that
goes this is like my third time using
class pass I feel like you have to say
it like class pass or clause pause Lisa
Vanderpump says a club I also watched
Vanderpump rules let's go again nothing
happened but I enjoyed it the end I'm
really like I was getting pissed off
because I'm like really annoyed with Tom
Schwartz everyone was making good points
that was my thing I agreed with Ariana
like why does it why is it now and
coming upon Tom's and all to invite him
when both of them and
like Tom Ford's be a man it's your wife
who doesn't want in there so you wanna
invite him no I felt like and you'll see
in my anagram test this is a perfect
example of it much like the college
cheating scandal where it's like I read
this side you're all right I read that
side you're all right I'm listening to
Tom Sanibel you're right and I'm
listening to Katie I'm like you're right
I don't know whose side I would take
right because Tom said it makes a great
point like all the people who work there
have said and done horrible things in
the restaurant and even next week they
show Lala bitching out while she's on
the job so it's like why does James get
fired for saying something to Katie when
all the when Katie called Lala [ __ ] in
the back parking lot when it's same fat
where James called her fat but then when
Katie starts to talk to stick I'm just
so done with people talking about my
body and it's like I agree and like
there is a line
yeah and James crossed it but like has
anyone else not crossed it I don't know
no it has but James done is worse than
all the things that Jax has done all the
things that kristen has done and they're
a very forgiving group I guess James
hasn't like apologized to katie directly
but it doesn't even seem like that would
mad like she is adamant like she wants
this guy out of Sur and out of the inner
Pemberton that's what it is by not
having him on the trip he's not a part
of the cast that's why he was crying and
that's why they're also they're not
talking they don't care if he comes on
the trip but the less he hangs out with
the group entirely the less reason he
has to be on the show and they think
they can eventually phase him out and
that's what they're trying to do but Tom
Sanibel and Ariana are not down no and
and I kind of understand both sides
because also when we're so like
diplomatic these days just like
understanding seeing everyone's
perspective I know I mean it's kind of
nice but then also you don't take a side
and then if you're damned if you do
you're damned if you don't because right
now if we took Katie side people and
also on the toast heating handle it all
comes back that you take one side and
all these people come for you take
another time all these people come for
you and it's also like there's an
element of sadness about it like that
and there's also an element of sadness
about this and like how Katie must feel
and being or having and as someone who's
been called fat in public and like
having people write about it on
Instagram and like anytime they bring it
up the James thing it just really nice
that conversation on Twitter like I know
when last night's episode or Monday
night's episode aired like that now
Kings body becomes a conversation again
on Twitter and it's [ __ ] annoying and
it's like we live in 2019 like I can't
believe that this is still happening so
I totally get why she is standing so
strong I'm like I think I would do the
same and I get pissed off at siesta key
where like didn't take enough action
against Paulie
yeah for a marason Chloe not once not
twice but three
and calling her fat and whale and
outcoming joke said she likes to have a
big dinner and like I wish the cast
members had been more like Katie on
Siesta Key we could use a little bit
more of that but then here's another
example like Schwartz last season called
scheana a bootleg Kardashian I mean
making fun of her love her face in her
looks and and how is that different
I completely agree but Katie seems to be
the only one like firmly taking a stand
maybe if anyone else had taken the stand
like maybe if Lala was like you know
Katie you called me a [ __ ] I call it as
I see it like you're female slut-shaming
whatever you're not empowering women
you're a woman who doesn't support other
women's Lisa I'm quitting unless Katie
you know what I mean like everyone
technically has an argument to be made
but it's like Katie's only one making it
yeah and then it's like with when
watching this and seeing that this group
is very forgiving and they've done
horrible things to each other I'm blah
blah blah and it's like why can't Katie
let this one thing go considering she's
got so many other things go it because
this one's personal yeah but I mean
they're all personal her husband made
out with another person like I know but
it's like I can't explain that unless
you've been called fat like you don't
know how embarrassing it is I was in
college reminded me of that the other
day you I forgot it I saw this girl we
were like oh my god you caught she
called you fat at a Halloween party in
high school that's all I'll ever know
her for and I literally had forgotten
cuz you were dressed as a cupcake she
was like that's funny cuz you're fat or
something like that oh my god I don't
know I was there and I was like really
upset about it he's like I don't where
was the party like it was some like loft
party okay I know there's just something
about being called fat that is different
I can't explain it like I would rather
be called a [ __ ] ten times I mean
called that one that's of course because
Society has like trained us I think like
that people are evil and disgusting
right we're and there's just like at
least you're cute no anyway roses made
it feel like it's cool to be fat I mean
to be a [ __ ] but I'm out here trying to
make it cool to me that we're not there
yet this is a song yeah like fat is like
the last demographic owned how Hollywood
hate stuff it has to happen on college
campuses first that's what it is okay
Hollywood hate the world like the way
that like average people think or talk
about even fat people and it's like a
loud and it's terrible it's terrible
like James next week calls it fatty oh
god that's horrible
no that's horrible there's like I can't
think of anything worse
than being called fat because it's
mortifying because Society has made us
think it's like if you're not tiny
you're ugly yeah and no and if you and
it's also just don't talk about my body
if you're overweight you are like a slab
of control so it's like you won't get a
job because oh she can't even do this
how could you know yeah and also there's
something deeply personal about it like
don't talk about my body like I am my
body is a temple my husband is my god
lumber yeah okay soon Durand will be
sending quotes by Alexis Bellino the
thinker of our time is she back on this
season of OC not that I'm aware of but
speaking of OC this video went viral
genome was in serum storing on the plane
while they were landing on one of their
trips they're filming and in the
background you can hear Kelly and
Shannon planning she's like okay I'm
gonna overreact and then you say this
Shaddai Shaddai also handle belly who I
love said maybe she meant fat PHA tea
she did no it's very possible she did
not because there was already some
existing beef yeah yeah all right you
guys thank you for being here thanks for
tuning into to 90-minute shows in a row
we're back tomorrow with hopefully
another 90-minute show just getting back
to tomorrow we're gonna do here toasters
oh yes so email to hearing your cries at
gmail.com which is hard by segment we
talk about a lot of things you know from
bridesmaids problems to family issues
but really we prefer the weird we're
hoarding water in our lawyer's office
basement kind of things so that steer
toasters at gmail.com we keep an
anonymous don't worry but like I'll show
you only let you up on Instagram and
that's all we got have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow and follow me I
check our phones
you